what's up guys today I'm going to show
tip how to make spareribs Riley how I
make spareribs yeah first that wherever
cooking together ever ever she never
cooks with me
uh-uh I hate the kitchen so we're going
to use this video as a way for her I'm
going to initiate her to the kitchen and
appreciation to make me spareribs
wouldn't that be the dream yes here I
got two slabs spareribs and they've both
been washed and haven't trimmed them yet
so I'm going to show you guys how to how
I trim them essentially this is a spare
rib not to get mixed up with the baby
bathroom with the paper there's two
parts of the rib against this despair is
the front size it's it's much I could
bone is straight the baby back grip is
on the side over here where if it curves
more and so that's called the baby back
ribs and that's why it's a guy this baby
I don't know why it's called alright so
I'm going to trim this st. louis-style
which is pretty much trimming it down to
just the rib so there's all this excess
meat over here this thingy majiggy here
you don't want that meat essentially
what people do is they cut this all off
over here and they use this for other
things you know you can't just grill it
eat it like that
you can't I do I do do that I usually
keep this stuff and I throw it on my
bottom section on my smoker and I use it
as a just like a little snack while I
wait for the ribs this up no you just
snack on
like listen look yeah what's going to
rich I know I pictured you eating it
wrong you just play with it it's so fun
okay you know tell me I wash my hands
and all my hair
so we're going to cut off this piece too
because isn't that part of the roof this
is the actual rib and so all this right
here beyond that that is called the rib
tips and that's not that's a whole
different dish right there
I've heard a good tip yeah you go to a
barbecue restaurant yeah and they have
rib tips knuckle though yeah I'm stupid
so all this stuff Stu or ripped is you
want to fight like that yeah this is my
job on this cooking video so this is the
actual rib and this is what you usually
see now when I couldn't in this is the
shade looks so pretty now you know it
didn't get prettier we're going to trim
it a little bit more I'm going to feel
for the bones and basically I'm looking
for the last rib that's going to be
worth eating
so if you imagine if you're a person and
you're obviously you're a person imagine
your first beer person what if you're a
person eating obviously you don't want
the tiny one right is a tiny one doesn't
give you a whole lot of meat to eat so
I'm going to look for the small one
starting with this one I think we're
gonna just cut it off because this
doesn't give anyone any satisfaction
there's a lot of meat a leave you don't
want to keep it no one it cooks faster
to get so yeah I got one consider the
cooking time so I'm going to get rid of
starting this one goodbye
and now the pole right can fit on there
tiny cut now we always manageable yeah
all right
to finish trimming it I'm going to get
rid of some excess fat can I do
yeah get rid of that fat right there
don't cut too much off though because
you want to keep a little bit effect as
the fats going to keep it moist and keep
it tender have no idea what I'm doing
chuckle you know what you're doing go
really just trim it away I think it's my
OCD myth I just want to get rid of all
the fat I'm like it's not clean I need
to clean it just no fat flavor though so
you don't want to get rid of the flavor
pick my nuts off there I'm going to flip
it over now on this side we have the
stain called membrane but the reason why
we didn't get the membrane off is
because we want our driver of our
seasonings to get into the meat and this
membrane gets in a way of that now I
kind of started it here what you want to
do is use your knife and you just want
to dig underneath that membrane and just
kind of raise it up there's more it's
hard yeah this is this is kind of like
the tricky part
so this membrane is very slippery and it
just slipped right off
did you trying to rip it off with your
hands the common knowledge is these
paper towels grab it with a paper towel
and you have way better traction you
just rip the rabo just like opening a
package it's like plastic anything you
couldn't play with that so take those
cut right here we're going to go ahead
and do the other one we have two racks
we got our two slabs Oh st. louis-style
cut spareribs and we're gonna put some
dry rub on it Rhaenys yellow mustard and
what the yellow mustard is for is not so
much for the flavor but more as a binder
for the dry rub binder Glu glutens are
an important other winners rub it in so
there's a coating of mustard so that
when we poured over our rope on that the
dry ropes gonna spit more good than me
so I just slept like a like a hot dog
yeah cool throw it on here yeah okay
let's transfer that's not a safe way to
grab a knife okay so you got the the
ridge transferred over into our pen and
yeah and now the moment we've all been
waiting for wood in that moment so we've
all heard of KC masterpiece barfi sauce
if you're never heard of KC's real
masterpiece dry rub Oh some
professionally made packaging skills see
that right there perfect alright so this
is a my own little concoction of dry rub
spring coil up in there yeah just
sprinkle it like how much tell you win a
lot you can sprinkle so much on there
one it's very low salt content in my dry
rub so you can just pack it on there the
thing you also pack on a lot of spices
in there so it's nice and flavorful you
literally want it to be all discolored
oh arm is getting tired
we have this driver recipe.i it took me
two years to get it to where I want it
to be I know I remember you every time
you used to make a rig I'd be like yeah
did it work no this one looks good and
then I see you in the kitchen like
trying to like contemplate how to make
it like perfect
I'm so happy you finally got it we are
now done with the prep we are going to
go outside start the grill over outside
now before we throw the ribs on the
smoker though I'm going to just mention
this thing right here so this is a
thermometer and for the smoker you want
it ideally in the great hot area where
it actually says smoke
so anything people hold up white dust
before the smoke area no good anything
above the gray area no good and ideally
you want a third party thermometer
that's like pretty good quality one cuz
some of these aren't that accurate
don't ones that come with the actual
smoker but I don't care I'm lazy like
that but essentially you for the ribs
you want like in between 220 to 230 v
but you don't want it any higher than
matches and you'll start cooking too
fast and with barbecue you wanted to do
a full all right so let's throw the ribs
on ready one two three four
it's magical cool you're like a witch
yeah take a whiff cold room they called
me a [ __ ] for a second I'm like wait
you feel like a [ __ ] okay Sherlock
where do you go do you try to just put
it near the center doesn't matter
doesn't matter it's really well even so
in this smoker I'm burning some
Applewood and some pecan wood and oh
good yeah to eat without the wood Apple
and become so just um good they make for
good pie and then there's also a water
pan in there that's gonna help hydrate
the meat and keep everything moist
inside that's about it I mean all the
hard work has been done we're going to
let it sit here for an hour come back
and check on it and stay tuned oh okay
smoke just do it I want to eat just get
like five hours really all right it's
been one hour and we're gonna check in
on the ribs to see how they're going
actually having peaked yet there's a
popular saying where it goes if you're
looking you ain't cooking and the reason
why they have that popular saying is
because if you look and then you lips oh
yeah and then you can't let it cook
because yeah I bring you I know that
because when I was in high school I had
this like phase or I was really into
baking I hope you guys find out what you
got airplane hey nice
please be already all right so it's
start playing thing so what's this thing
you gave me this is pineapple juice whoo
tastes like pineapple juice mmm
refreshing all right so the dry rub that
I put on here has no sugar with the
webrinoa our dry rub they like to put
brown sugar in it to give it a little
sweetness but for me I like to kind of
keep it savory first and then slowly
implement some sugars now so with the
spritz right with the spritz we're going
to introduce some moisture and some
sugars coat it yeah make it nice and
glossy for us drench it pan which is
something if you don't want the outside
of try out that's pretty much the reason
and that's it I did yeah our first hour
looks pretty good each hour will come
back with a spray bottle and we'll give
it a nice little back into the darkness
you go all right another hour has passed
and we're gonna spray it again yeah yeah
seems looking pretty good
then we go back to sleeping up no we
weren't sleeping I'm working so it's
been three hours even waiting we've been
working my whirlwind but while we've
been waiting was in the editing videos
and stuff so moment of truth this is
what it looks like after three hours you
there nice and brown
oh got that nice tits on it we're gonna
transfer these over into here now and
take it off the smoker now because we're
going to put it in that text crutch that
wrap we're gonna add some sugar some
brown sugar and some putting into it and
we're gonna really just kind of finalize
it with all the flavors that we've had
in the dry rub and in the sugars now
cool I guess another thing to us if
you're wondering while we're doing three
hours here and then and they're gonna
wrap it up this is called a three to one
method and the three to one method is
pretty much three hours on smokers two
hours in a wrap and then one hour
additional on top of that unwrapped and
on the smoker alright so first things
first
basically the dry rub is all salts and
all spices so you want to add that
sweetness to it to give it that barbecue
flavor so what we're going to do is open
for honey what we're gonna do is create
our hot dog mustard pattern like that
roughly ballpark the l'homme have all
over the lid and they're going to take a
brown sugar I'm going to drill some of
it on here I'm gonna start on Maddy
yeah wash your hand I can cool little
bit how much would you say is here like
a cup two cups I have no idea i eyeball
everything from the boss party your true
chef that was about good for today today
I'm feeling this much alright so we're
going to take a rib so what we're going
to do is you want to put it meat side
down not where you cut the membrane but
they're not the membrane side but the
side where all the fat was I'm going to
put it down meat side the reason for
that is we're actually going to cook it
upside down like this from here on out
because we want all the remaining fat to
melt into the meat side so it's nice and
juicy and tender and also when all the
sugars from the honey and a brown sugar
to kind of stew and basically work it
braising the rest of the ribs for the
remainder of the cook Wow that's facing
down we're also going to dress it the
backside with more honey and we're gonna
trigger the honey I don't do the sugar
sugar
now it's next is we're doing the actual
wrap I see no more bunch of different
people if videos do it differently but
I'm just going to do it like
this is how my brain works pull it that
way go up this way my OCD is kicking in
can I sell our calling up a layaway plan
pervy OTG for the men all right like
that and we're going to put it meat side
down just like that so we're gonna keep
the bowls on the top side
you're like Chipotle workers and do very
well handle the foil Joey's like
struggle with it first let me get like
man another burrito is like a captain
did I finish it
alright so we're taking them boys
outside now and we are gonna throw them
on the grill and face it they're gonna
braise in their own juices for two hours
but then for me sometimes it one and a
half should do the job - so Anibal all
kind of ballpark it alright if in an
hour and a half nice and hot Wow Oh
crispy crispy and black thing yes okay
barbecue so what you're seeing is the
crispy part that is known as the the
bark whoa and this is what we're looking
at this is what I want to show you the
pull back on the bones that's how you
know it's right cuz it likes before yeah
it shrinks before it would cover up the
entire foam but when it starts pulling
back that's when you know it is ready
pretty much you can heat it now if you
really wanted to so where you put it for
one more hour back another boy this is
this is done why this is because you can
eat this this is gorgeous I think who
put it back on there for about 30
minutes unwrapped them that way we can
kind of just tighten up the meat a
little bit more so it's gonna have a
good bite to it - cool you better not
touch it again gosh I won't
all right it has been 30 minutes and it
is time to finally do what we've all
been waiting for that is the final cut
one open and see what it looks like on
the inside all right this is what we got
this is our rib on the outside it looks
like poop so that's how the bark how
like a like a tree tree bark yeah and
we're gonna cut it upside down I'm just
kind of want to split it in snow let's
lick on the inside and so the smoked
meringue is pretty much on the edges of
the rib that's like a clear indication
as to how much smoke I'm into me and how
much smoke flavor will be in the meat
when you eat it baby
they're so soft mmm install this boys
right off the phone - yeah called rental
car we did a good job brother did we we
gonna give your job
hey hey you come your sous-chef you want
my shoes back all right guys if you
enjoyed this video make sure to give it
a big thumbs up
who's our first cooking video give a big
thumbs up for chef Casey over here casey
matt poppy and also comment down below
what other recipes you'd like to see us
create for you guys alright guys so see
you next time